- Alright, before we roll the credits.
I've got one last story
I can't wait to share.
This is What I'm Liking.
Y'all get ready, for some
awesome female power.
This story is crazy.
This summer four women
braved the open water
in a thirty foot boat in
the Great Pacific Race.
They rode from San Francisco to Honolulu.
In thirty-four days, fourteen
hours and twenty minutes.
Breaking a world record.
Say hello to the women of team Lat 35.
Adrienne, Brooke, DJ and Libby.
(audience cheers)
Congratulations, y'all.
- Hi, Kelly.
- This is incredible.
I feel so lazy, like talking to you.
But Adrienne and Libby,
I'll start with y'all.
Tell us more about the
boat and the conditions.
- So, you got it right
the boat is thirty feet
and we have two cabins
that we would sleep in.
We spend two hours
rowing and then two hours
doing other things.
Twenty-four hours a day,
for thirty-four days.
- Oh my gosh.
- In our off shifts,
when we're not rowing.
We kinda do everything
else and it involves like
making food, cleaning the
boat, fixing equipment.
Any incoming storms,
you got to prep it for.
So you kinda just have
to like go with the flow.
With everything that comes your way.
Which is quite exciting.
When you're out there
just all on your own.
- I love that you say that's exciting.
I would be terrified of a
big storm on a little boat.
But, Brooke.
I hear that the Olympics
might be in your future.
Right?
- Yeah, before this I
was training full time.
In hopes of making the National Team.
And when I was out in
the middle of the ocean
I realized I had some unfinished business
with flat water.
So, I'm getting back into training.
In hopes of going to the Paris 24
or Los Angeles 28.
- Wow, well congratulations.
It's incredible.
Thank you for showing us what we are
actually capable of.
So, well I don't have to.
Alright so, DJ.
Y'all are raising money, right?
- Yeah, so as Libby described.
We had a pretty grueling schedule.
But, we did end up having
actually a ton of fun.
We were able to listen to lots of music.
Sing a lot.
We actually had a karaoke night.
Pretty much every night and we sang lots
of Kelly Clarkson.
- Yes!
- Especially, "Since You've Been Gone."
And another really meaningful thing for us
was that we were able
to raise twelve-thousand
dollars for the Anxiety and Depression
Association of America.
(audience cheers)
Which was a really important cause for us.
- Wow.
You're doing something cool, that you love
and also helping people.
That's amazing.
Way to go, ladies!
Your purpose is magical
and good luck with the future Olympics.
Everybody.
I'm liking your post right now.
It's so cool what y'all've done.
Congratulations on
breaking that world record.
That's not all, though.
Our season long partner Pilot Pin Makers
the G2, the go to pin of
the Kelly Clarkson show.
Want to honor truly unstoppable people.
Just like y'all.
So, they'll be writing
a check in your honor.
To the Anxiety and Depression Association
of America, for one-thousand dollars.
(audience cheers)
- Aw, thank you.
- [Kelly] Thank you ladies, so much.
You're so tough.
I love it, thank you for coming on.